are you seeing red after watching those
two characters still not get the chance
to meet in one Piece Film red and is the
newest one-piece film in continuity or
not anime films typically have a tricky
place and continuity with franchises
like Dragon Ball often excluding them
from Canon while other properties like
my hero Academia incorporate them into
the wider continuity one piece tends to
land somewhere in the complicated Middle
with its treatment of Canon in regard to
the handling of its spin-off anime films
and one Piece Film red is no exception
to make matters all the more potentially
convoluted red is produced and based on
a story from One Piece Creator Hiro Oda
serving as an extension of oda's vision
for the franchise several elements of
red have already carried over into the
manga anime series story specifically
the character utta and her lifelong
connection to Luffy as childhood friends
with him a young utta appears in
episodes 1029 and 1030 of the anime
series as Shanks adopted daughter though
she's left behind by the crew in the
flashback rad sees utta and Shanks
finally reuniting and reconciling by the
end of the movie and utta rejoins the
red hair Pirates though the full extent
of how the movie's story itself impacts
the main narrative is currently unknown
puta and her place in continuity are a
loose plot thread practically begging to
be followed up on on the other hand
there are several elements and character
depictions in red that either clash with
the series overarching timeline or
simply contradict the established Canon
as it currently stands Luffy showcasing
his powerful gear 5 transformation and
jinbei being present among the straw hat
Pirates suggests that the events of red
take place after the wano country story
arc however red also features the
villains behind wano country the big mom
pirates in a prominent way despite their
defeat in the series this isn't to say
that the big mom Pirates couldn't have
regrouped under unseen circumstances but
it does undercut kid and law defeating
them in wano country according to the
filmmakers red is something of a side
story that doesn't neatly fit into the
main story allowing for just
discrepancies like Jim Bay's raw though
tying into narrative elements like
Luffy's childhood with this in mind red
works like something of a teaser for
elements potentially coming to the main
Series in the future
though Shanks and the red hair Pirates
have loomed large in Luffy's life and
his decision to become a pirate himself
red puts the pirate crew front and
center in contrast to previous films in
the franchise when red was released in
Japanese Cinemas in August 2022
screenings handed out a special program
to provide more background on the film
and its characters including the red
hair Pirates this program offers more
information about Shanks and utta in
particular proving backstory not
explicitly stated or shown in the film
itself
the program reveals that Shanks and utta
share a common origin story with both
discovered inside of a treasure chest by
Pirates while they were left alone as
infants just as Shanks was adopted by
the Legendary Pirate Captain Goldie
Roger Shanks in turn adopted utta after
he found her the five Elders making up
the reigning world government of One
Piece describe both Shanks and utta
belonging to the fearland family
descendants of the Royals that used to
rule the world the primary antagonist of
red is utta who appears to be an
innocent pop star looking to restore the
devastated island of elegia and bring
music to the masses in a Festival
concert the straw hat Pirates are
surprised to learn that utta is shanks's
adopted daughter and a childhood friend
of Luffy before she unveils her grand
plan in order to unite Humanity through
peace and Harmony UTSA plans to use her
unique abilities to draw her audience's
Consciousness into the dream world to
eliminate interpersonal Strife in the
real world with Luffy and his friends
realizing this scheme would effectively
Rob Humanity of its Free Will in the
process they move to stop her however
utta herself undergoes a shocking
Discovery when she realizes her powers
are responsible for devastating eligia
in the first place this sets utta on a
path for Redemption and one that she
still may be pursuing should the
character resurface in the anime series
Beyond her flashback appearances to
Luffy's childhood Luffy's long-lost
friend may have been introduced as a pop
Idol with adoring masses but like many
characters in one piece she has a dark
history to overcome the rubber-like
powers Luffy gained after eating a piece
of devil fruit has led him to achieve
various combat Transformations as he
continues to awaken his latent potential
red features Luffy's most powerful
transformed state yet known as gear 5 as
he battles an ancient demon residing
within the dream world that threatens to
break free into the waking world in the
comics Luffy first achieves the gear 5
transformation during the wano country
storyline in the middle of his final
showdown against the villainous kaido
now aware of the full extent of his
connection to the devil fruit Luffy
gains absolute Mastery over his powers
as he unveils this combat transformation
in red Luffy transforms into gear 5 to
take on the demon taught musica within
the dream world having grown visibly
accustomed to the ability use the new
form grandson this suggests that Luffy
won't have any issues tapping into his
gear 5 potential moving forward one
piece has introduced different Realms
and dimensions to the narrative's
material world one Piece Film red goes
one step further by prominently
featuring a dream world connected to
utta through her music with devastating
implications for the waking world
through Power is gained by eating a
devil fruit UTA can draw people who hear
her music into the dreaming world with
Buddha planning to shape their
Consciousness accordingly my music will
set you free and we'll all live happily
together in
the dream world isn't unpopulated
however with an ancient demon known as
the tut musica residing within and
plotting to escape into the real world
to unleash chaos and destruction a
flashback late in red reveals utta
accidentally allowed to talk musica to
enter the real world 12 years before the
events of the film devastating the
island of elegia though taught musica is
destroyed by the combined efforts of the
straw hats and red hair Pirates The
Experience makes utta reconsider her
powers there may be additional monsters
lurking in the dream world and having
gotten a taste of the outside world this
new dimension adds more complexity and
Peril to the world of One Piece
one of the major antagonists of the wano
country story arc are the big bomb
Pirates a rival faction that has held a
long-standing deep grudge against Luffy
and are led by their power-hungry
Captain Charlotte linlan after their
botched alliance with kaido and the
Beast Pirates to conquer the world the
big mom Pirates were last seen trying to
rescue Charlotte from a fiery fate in
the wake of their defeat not only are
the big mom Pirates back in red but they
appear to be restored in strength and
just as dangerous as ever seeking new
ways to subjugate Humanity witnessing
Pluto's Powers firsthand during her
concert on eligia island the big man
Pirates attempt to kidnap utta to
exploit her devil fruit powers for
themselves though the pirate crew is
unsuccessful the crew's appearance in
the movie is a welcome reminder that
recent defeat or not the big man Pirates
are a dangerous enemy to have the red
hair pirates and their Captain
red-haired Shanks have been regarded as
one of the most notorious pirate crews
in the new world for years despite their
more heroic actions in the movie they
play a pivotal role in not only stopping
utta from misusing her powers to unleash
taught musica but helping her recover
from the ordeal however utta's
impressive abilities haven't gone
unnoticed especially by the Navy and the
world government believing utta to be
too dangerous to be allowed to roam free
the Admirals planned to bring the pop
star into custody Shanks is able to
intervene and get the Admirals to stand
down bringing utta onto his crew of red
hair Pirates before departing from the
island for Parts Unknown now with utta
in tow Shanks and the red hair Pirates
are more wanted by the authorities than
ever Shanks and his crew's reputation
gives them a fair bit of leeway on the
Open Seas but with a musical secret
weapon in their midst the red hair
Pirates may have just become the world's
most wanted more than utta being Luffy's
long-lost childhood friend the biggest
Revelation coming out of red is why the
Beloved pop star was separated from
shanks's crew Shanks is revealed to have
left utta behind as he sailed the new
world with his red-haired Pirates when
she was still at an early age this
abandonment causes utta to strongly
resent all Pirates due to their
association with shanks's decision to
leave her straining her friendship with
Luffy when he sets out to follow and
shanks's footsteps after stopping utta
from unleashing tat musica and saving
her life Shanks finally accepts utta as
his daughter welcoming her to join him
with the red hair Pirates Shanks is also
fiercely protective of utta when the
Admirals attempt to take her into
custody with utta now serving alongside
them Shanks not only has his daughter by
his side but the red hair Pirates
potentially have their most powerful
crewmate yet red effectively humanizes
Shanks by bringing his daughter into the
fold while hinting at Further Adventures
Together in the main series moving
forward
Luffy truly owes everything to Shanks
with the Pirates saving his life as a
boy at the cost of one of his arms not
only is Luffy forever indebted to Shanks
for this but after receiving shank's
signature Straw Hat as a gift to
remember him by Luffy decided to follow
in his Idol's footsteps to lead a pirate
crew himself Luffy and Shanks promise to
reunite someday always just missing each
other over the course of one piece with
red continuing this narrative tradition
despite the two ostensibly working
together though Luffy and Shanks lead
their respective pirate Crews to work
together to stop utta and Destroy taught
musica the two captains don't actually
encounter each other over the course of
red this largely has to do with the
dimensional separation stemming from the
dream world with Luffy inside of the
dream world to confront tot musica while
Shanks remains elsewhere as Shanks and
his crew depart from eligia Island at
the end of the film he still hasn't
reunited with Luffy to see how far the
boy he saved has come as a pirate in his
own right with the promise unfulfilled
Luffy and Shanks still have unfinished
business between them to eventually
resolve
film red does include a post-credits
scene that shows Luffy back on his
pirate ship sailing away from elegia
Island for new adventures as he
contemplates his recent experiences just
as determined as ever Luffy declares to
the Open Sea that he will one day become
the king of the Pirates a lifelong
ambition he has maintained since
childhood red offers more insight into
Luffy's long-standing dream with his
adventure with utta reaffirming why he
intends to seize this position among the
pirate community in the New World by the
end of the film after reconciling with
her father and seeing the error of her
ways utta expresses her confidence in
Luffy one day achieving his dream the
esteemed role in the pirate Community
has remained vacant since the passing of
shank's Mentor gold D Roger leading
various pirate captains to bicker
amongst themselves for the title now
with a vote of confidence from his
childhood friend Luffy is more
determined than ever to finally become
king of the Pirates
[Music]
foreign
[Music]